Design is a collaborative process. And to promote
collaboration in this course, we've built a space where
you and your fellow classmates can meet, discuss
the course and share course deliverables for feedback. Let
me give you a tour. To access the forum, just click on the Forum icon or the
Start a Discussion button from any course page. The
forum will open in a new tab. And you'll
see that it's organized by categories for each
lesson and the final project, in addition to
a few other categories. Categories consist of instructor
defined topics which you'll see are pinned to
the top of the list in addition to
topics started by students. After creating a user
name, you're free to navigate interesting topics, post
questions, and even answer some questions yourself. To post
your response to a question, just click the
reply button and start typing. At various times in
the course, you'll want to upload deliverables to share
with classmates. To do so, click the appropriate lesson
or project category, navigate to the topic you
want to address and remember, instructor initiated topics are
always pinned to the top. Click the reply button,
and stat typing. You can also upload photos or
other files by selecting the upload button. Each udacity
course page has a section titled discussions, and any
questions found there are directly related to the information
shown in the video on that page. You can add
your own question to the course page by clicking
the ask a question button, and typing in your question.
If you get lost while using the forum, just
click the home icon in the top left hand corner
to come back to the forum home page. Now give it a shot, go
to the forum and tell us why you're taking the Design of Everyday Things